dans les yvelines cinq cas ont été
recensés depuis le mois d'avril
inquiets les propriétaires d'équidés met
tout en oeuvre pour protéger leurs
chevaux et leurs structures d'éventuels
les attaquent la partie écuries étaient
déjà sécurisé avec des caméras remet et
aujourd'hui on va essayer de remettre
des caméras de re sécuriser la partie
prairie la partie ont acquis et la pluie
la plus vulnérable au jour d'aujourd'hui
et en ce moment on a un maître chien
vizille une société de gardiennage qui
viennent toutes les nuits à surveiller
les prairies et le poney club
un dispositif essentiel pour le
directeur des écuries mais qui a un coût
c'est un surcoût énorme pour les écuries
mais on veut rassurer nos clients on a
des chevaux de propriétaires on a les
chevaux du poney club des enfants qui
viennent toutes les semaines il faut
pour la rentrée puis se retrouver tous
les pots na qui connaissent des groupes
facebook fermé ont aussi été créés ils
permettent de signaler tout comportement
suspect aux abords des centres équestres
et des prix dans les yvelines deux
cavaliers de la garde républicaine ont
notamment pour mission de faire de la
prévention auprès des et qui tend il les
appelle à ne pas se faire justice eux
mêmes la solution c'est plutôt vers le
17 pour vous préserver de l'agression
enfers de 17 et prendre un maximum de
renseignements à visuellement en plaques
d'immatriculation ne pas rentrer en
contact avec cette personne
les gendarmes ont multiplié leurs
services tournés vers le monde de
l'équitation
nous renforçons le contact auprès des
éleveurs des différents centres
équestres mais aussi des différents et
qui tend afin de leur devenir une
conduite à suivre mais aussi les
rassurer au maximum afin de d'éviter
qu'ils qu'ils paniquent
quoi qu'il en soit quinze mille chevaux
et 800 propriétaires vivent dans les
yvelines la gendarmerie les invite à se
manifester pour se faire enregistrer
dans leur base de données